[Music]
let's go to jennifer in ann arbor
michigan what's up jennifer
how much how are you good are you a huge
ohio state fan uh no
[Laughter]
uh no
in fact i'm hanging up
how are you
i'm okay i'm okay just dealing with um
some family issues aren't we all right
like what you got what you got
so
um at the end of september my mom died
oh can we just park there for a second
what was her name
uh catherine oh how she had she had she
passed away
she um actually had als but we didn't
find that out until the january january
of that year so okay she passed about 10
months uh yeah almost 10 months after we
found out i'm so sorry
that's okay
she'd been dealing with something we
couldn't that nobody could figure it out
for a couple of years
um so it was good that she passed
quickly because she was basically
bedridden
what's so hard that's so hard on
everybody man
yeah oh so then the family showed up
then what happened
um well that all went okay
but um
two weeks ago my dad called and dropped
a bomb on me
and the bomb is that he's getting
remarried he's gonna say is he getting
married oh my gosh
to who
somebody from church that he's only
known for about three months
um
and
you know that
my dad was the
youngest child
of six
and when he moved out from his parents
he moved in with my uncle and then he
met my mom and married my mom and moved
in with my mom so he's never lived alone
and had to take care of himself okay
so i understand that he's really
lonely and probably hungry too
but the thing that bothered me i wasn't
even really upset that he was going to
move on i wasn't even really upset about
that how old
um he'll be 72 this year okay all right
um what i'm upset about though is that
he
didn't even give like one
second
thought about
me in this whole process and i'm his
only child i have a half brother but
he's my mom's son
um
you know like he never told me he was
dating anybody he never told me that he
was spending time with anyone
and i would i you know i called him
weekly because he knew i knew he was
lonely he only had the dog in the tv for
company
um
you know he was like he didn't
he didn't want me there yeah
um can i reframe it for you
sure
i just i just
talked to somebody recently um very
similar experience very similar age
and
the word um
and they've started talking to somebody
and
the word they kept coming up over and
over was guilt
guilt guilt guilt guilt
and i'm imagining a scenario right i'm
making this up
so there's two stories here one is your
dad's a jerk he's cutting his daughter
out he's like screw you i only got 20
years left i'm gonna ride to the wheels
fall off and you're not a part of it
that could be story one okay
story two could be
i wanna give my daughter as much time as
possible to grieve her mama
and the picture of our family
and the good stuff and the bad stuff and
the messy stuff i don't wanna break her
heart but god i'm lonely too
and then miss thang just walks in here
to the church and then it's all right
and then that happens
and
then celine dion starts playing and the
whole thing just here we go so yeah
i think there's really two ways you can
move forward
one way is you can sit down and tell
your dad hey dad i just need you to know
this hurt my feelings
yeah
um
you don't even know um the rest of this
oh okay bring it bring it
so
i i i did talk to my dad and you know he
said he was sorry for hurting me i'm
like you're not hurting me that you want
to get married you're hurting me that
you're excluding me from it okay so hold
on can we just stop it god this is like
the show of bravery good for you
you expressed your feelings to your dad
man
what a rock star this [ __ ] this is like
the this is like i'm gonna put all three
of y'all's faces on the cover of the
show i won't actually do that but
wow so i i rarely talk they're like what
i can tell my dad how i feel good for
you and then it went sideways so what
happened
it did go sideways so he
he said
um
well well
because my my knee we're already coming
down to texas for my niece's wedding
in about two months she's getting
married at the end of may
and i said can't you know can't you wait
until we're down there in may like you
know two of my boys are going to be able
to come and
chris my husband and i will be down
there and
could we wait so that we could all be
together and do this
and he said well i'll talk to her and
then she actually messaged me on
facebook and said they were going to
wait but then my mom's
best friend called me and said your dad
just came over here and invited us to
the wedding and it's april 2nd
so they're not waiting
did you call your dad back
called me and told me that they decided
not to wait did you call them back
no i haven't
i haven't i just did all of this
praising about how brave you were and i
take it all back all of it i'm just
kidding
i just wasn't i wasn't sure
i i wasn't i don't know i kind of feel
like it's his responsibility as my dad
to call me and say hey
i know we told you we're gonna wait but
we're not gonna wait and you know you
can stream the wedding from the church
and and here's what day we're doing at
what what time we're doing it but he
hasn't done that and so i just i don't
know i didn't know if i should call him
and call him out or
i i if based on what you've told me
about your relationship with him so far
i would
because i i'm not
especially like a message from somebody
else from somebody else on facebook i'm
not gonna let that affect my physiology
and biology until i can just talk to the
real person
yeah
and so i'm just gonna
yeah
i would be on the phone just like did
you move your wedding up to april 2nd or
i just got a message from a message that
you moved your wedding up to april 2nd
is that accurate
and
part of me and my guts thinks that you
know that's probably actually what's
happening
is that what you think oh yeah my my
half brother told me yeah that dad
touched me and invited me to the wedding
and it's on april 2nd
hmm
it's okay like so all of all the stuff i
said earlier if you're listening to this
show and it applies to you great
jennifer i'm just gonna say i'm sorry
that sucks
it does like your dad kind of host you
and i'm sorry
yeah
i wish it wasn't like that and there's
part of you that feels like you're it's
not it's not
it feels like you lost two parents
that's yeah that's hard
yeah i feel like you know she's got
three daughters they all live down there
he's got a new family and it's
we're moving forward and
you know you're part of the past so yeah
i mean i don't really think that he
feels like that but that's kind of how
it's making me feel
1 000
and it's hard when you've expressed your
feelings and the person in front of you
says i hear you thank you so much then
they go do exactly opposite or they're
dishonest with you
right it's brutal man that gets in your
soul right
ugh i'm sorry that happened
so yeah i wish i had another nicer
weight like your dad's just hosing you
he's not be he's allowed to do whatever
he wants to do
he's he's not being a person of
character he's not being a person of
integrity he's not respecting his
daughter and i'm sorry because you
deserve all three of those things
your dad's integrity your dad's respect
and um i i hate that for you man
so ultimately
when it all distills down
you can't do a single thing about him
his actions his thoughts his
love for this woman none of that
right all you can deal with is you so my
question for you is what's next what are
you gonna do
oh
that's why i haven't called him because
i i just wasn't sure how i wanted to
handle it okay yeah it sounds like the
two paths forward are to get in touch
with them and say hey did you move your
thing to april 2nd
and not in a mean and not in an
exasperated way just a factual facts of
your friends like hey did you move this
to april 2nd
um
and you know what you could do you could
send flowers just like we can't make it
on that day and we already told joe we
can send flowers and we wish you all the
best
and in four months when this thing's off
the rails being weird and he calls you
then you can make that choice then um
the other thing you can do is go to war
and i just
you got a guy who's broken and grieving
and war is not he's just gonna end up in
piles of bodies why you know what i mean
yeah yeah i do um
i don't think your dad's moving on from
you forever i think your dad is found a
tiny flashlight in a giant pit of
despair
and
it's a something that he just keeps
staring directly into the middle of
and i think that will resurface in a few
months maybe i'm nuts
maybe your dad hasn't liked you ever and
this is his moment to finally escape
jennifer finally and he's gonna be on
the front row with his face painted in
ohio state garb
maybe that's the case
um and he's been in your michigan family
forever
my guess is probably not
but i will say this just as your friend
i'm sorry you deserve better than that
thank you
i wish there was another thing i wish i
could give you like another thing that's
just kind of is what it is
no yeah that's what my husband says too
and hey let's be super on is there
anything worse than when your husband's
like right
oh it's the worst
my husband's always right
somebody finally said it somebody
finally said it well jennifer i'm so
grateful for you um thanks for calling
and walking us through and letting me
throw all my thesis theses thesises
these i don't want to say that all of my
uh
thoughts against a wall but yeah man
that's just hard i'm sorry being left
out at the new wedding and the new life
and the new all of this
so so hard
if i'm you i'd call them that's the best
i can say i'd call them say hey did you
move to april 2nd and then i'm going to
send flowers and then i'm gonna move on
and i hate that i hate that hate that
kid is your dad